last week in geneva russian foreign
minister lavrov and i met to discuss the
crisis
instigated by russia's military buildup
on ukraine's borders
and steps to de-escalate tensions and
pursue diplomacy
russia had previously outlined its
concerns and proposals in writing and
last week i told foreign minister lavrov
the united states would do the same
today
master sullivan delivered our written
response in moscow
all told it sets out a serious
diplomatic path forward should russia
choose it
the document we've delivered includes
concerns of the united states and our
allies and partners about russia's
actions that undermine security
a principled and pragmatic evaluation of
the concerns that russia has raised
and our own proposals for areas where we
may be able to find common ground
we make clear that there are core
principles that we are committed to
uphold and defend
including ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and the right of
states to choose their own security
arrangements and alliances
we've addressed the possibility of
reciprocal transparency measures
regarding forced posture in ukraine as
well as measures to increase confidence
regarding military exercises and
maneuvers in europe
and we address other areas where we see
potential for progress
including arms control related to
missiles in europe
our interest in a follow-on agreement to
the new start treaty that covers all
nuclear weapons
and ways to increase transparency and
stability
we put these ideas forward because they
have the potential
if negotiated in good faith to enhance
our security and that of our allies and
partners
while also addressing russia's stated
concerns through reciprocal commitments
our response to russia reflects what i
said in kiev berlin and geneva last week
we're open to dialogue
we prefer diplomacy
and we're prepared to move forward
where there is the possibility of
communication cooperation
if russia de-escalates its aggression
toward ukraine stops the inflammatory
rhetoric
and approaches discussions about the
future security in europe in a spirit of
reciprocity
our responses were fully coordinated
with ukraine and our european allies and
partners
with whom we've been consulting
continuously for weeks
we sought their input and incorporated
it into the final version delivered to
moscow
additionally
nato developed and will deliver to
moscow its own paper with ideas and
concerns about collective security in
europe and that paper fully reinforces
ours and vice versa
there's no daylight among the united
states and our allies and partners on
these matters
we shared our response paper with
congress
and i'll be briefing congressional
leaders on this later today
and consulting with them on our approach
as you know
there's strong bipartisan interests and
deep expertise on the hill when it comes
to ukraine and russia and we very much
appreciate having congress as a partner
as we move forward
we're not releasing the document
publicly because we think that diplomacy
has the best chance to succeed if we
provide space for confidential talks
we hope and expect that russia will have
the same view and will take our proposal
seriously the secretary of defense
announced on monday
that 8 500 u.s service members currently
stationed in europe and the united
states
have been placed in heightened readiness
of heightened readiness to deploy to
ensure that we're able to support the
nato response force swiftly if it's
activated by the north atlantic council
to harden the allies eastern flank
other nato allies have also announced
steps that they're prepared to take
and we expect more in the coming days
we've taken this step out of prudence
uh we hope those forces don't have to be
activated for deployment
but if they are
we will be ready
we're also continuing to coordinate with
our european allies and partners on
severe economic sanctions
to hold moscow accountable for its
actions
we've developed a high impact quick
action response that would inflict
significant costs on the russian economy
and financial system
as part of our response
we're also prepared to impose export
controls that will have a longer-term
effect
denying russia products that it needs to
fulfill its strategic ambitions
on top of all of that
our allies and partners are also
stepping up to provide assistance to
ukraine in various and mutually
reinforcing ways it remains up to russia
to decide how to respond
we're ready either way